cycling is one of the healthiest and
most environmentally friendly ways of
getting from A to B we believed followed
our car testify no dicen / says the
numbers bear this out with about seventy
two million bikes in Germany many people
who want to ride their own bike on
holiday bring it with them either on top
on the back or inside the car but safety
experts aren't too fond of roof bike
racks toy guns antics patent beenish me
guys that a bird cutler owns a bike shop
and he's familiar with all the different
bike transportation systems mother says
roof racks are suited only to
lightweight racing bikes they're easier
to lift and the mounting equipment
doesn't have to be quite so sturdy bikes
on the roof may vibrate or sway and that
can be dangerous really say so that
leaves inside the car or on the back
hitch mounted bike racks are especially
useful on longer trips the bike rack is
attached to the trailer hitch on the car
a turn of the key and the rack is
secured then hook up the electrical
connection for the trailers rear lights
mount the bikes on the rack and secure
them
dammit I note has a few tips to make
mounting faster and easier it's best to
remove everything that's detachable and
heavy from your bike first that includes
the water bottle and the bike basket
then there's ebikes an e-bike can weigh
30 kilos and the battery is heavy and
expensive so it's best to remove the
battery and the speedometer which could
fall off and put those in your car
Vatutin sport Ian Dan the Tuskens
elkwood the number of bikes you can
transport depends on your car's
permitted load weight so be sure to
check that first I know says it even if
you're not slowed down by Sun rain or
other glitches remember thieves are
everywhere so be sure to lock up your
bikes too and put a license plate on the
rack since your car is plate is hidden
Sonia comea your car will be longer with
the rack on it so parking aids won't
work properly and the extra weight also
affects handling
inside the car your bikes will travel in
comfort but you'll have less space for
passengers and cargo of course clamping
the bikes to an inside bike rack is a
simple process
that's what me besides of seamless I
know says a universal system makes
adjusting the rack to the width of your
car a snap remove the bikes front wheel
put the bike in the trunk securing the
bike fork and you're done
whatever kula says that if you have
expensive bikes inside racks are nice
because you're not risking scratches
damage or dirt and their theft proof so
inside your car your bikes will usually
be safe with the bike safely stowed
inside the car you can set off with an
inside rack driving speed isn't an issue
but rear mounted racks can come with
speed restrictions so be sure to check
your user's manual mounting instructions
and any rating plates on the rack and
whatever the speed limit for your rack
is best to stay under 130 kilometers an
hour on the highway